to these ladies these two girls Phoebe
Plummer and N Anna Holland chose to
protest in their own way and they are
part of the the just oil activist and
they threw soup all over Van Gogh's
iconic sunflower painting and they glued
themselves to the wall and they're out
of UK and this was a trending topic all
over the place people were talking about
it there we go we have them all at that
time and I simply want to know what
they're protesting and I want to give
them the eyeball to share with us what
they were really protesting so if we
have you on uh uh uh If Phoebe is that
you are you and I'm sorry if I don't
know the two names
Anna how are you
very good first of all thank you for uh
agreeing to do this and being on we were
trying to do it I think last week
something happened uh sometime we had it
like three four days ago and then we
ended up doing it today so if you don't
mind take a quick moment what I just set
it up as yourself and your friend Phoebe
you guys are part of the just oil
activists you two chose to through uh
throw soup all over Van Gogh's iconic
sunflower painting and you glued
yourself to the wall can you can you
share with us what point you were trying
to make
yeah absolutely so in just up oil our
demands are that the government should
end all new fossil fuel licenses okay so
currently trying to push forward a
hundred new fossil fuel licenses which
will without a doubt kill us it's a
genocidal policy but they're trying to
push forward so in just stop oil we are
trying to prevent that from happening
we're trying to save not just ourselves
but our children are our families so we
decided to throw soup over Van Gogh's
painting as a way not just to make a
statement about that and to get a people
finally talking about this climate
crisis but also to get people talking
about the cost of living crisis which is
fueled by the same people who are
pushing forward to this climate crisis
well you listen whether you're getting
criticized for your approach or not you
got eyeballs and you got attention so
what you were trying to get accomplished
you got it and people uh paid attention
to what you're what you're doing but now
you said your concern is that this could
kill us this could get pretty up ugly
can you unpack that a little bit for us
on your argument
yeah um you know so
appliances
26 years ago we have created more
emissions than the entire Humanity up
until that point right now it is a
matter of political will in needing to
change this rather than the science not
being there you know this summer in the
UK and the heat wave we lost a third of
our wheat crops we're set to lose half
of our potato crops we're heading
towards Mass famine right now 33 million
people are displaced by floods in
Pakistan 36 million people are facing
severe famine in East Africa right now
the climate crisis isn't a problem of
the future we're seeing the catastrophic
effects of it right now can I ask you
what great are you guys in high school
or in college
and we're both University students okay
yes I'm 20. listen please take that as a
compliment that you look young don't
don't take it by anything it's just you
look like you could be high school or
college So what at what point did the
climate crisis become a concern of yours
do you remember how old you were when
the climate crisis became a concern of
yours and what was the setting when you
sat there and said you know we better
start paying attention to this was it
early in high school was it in junior
high school or is this a recent thing
well I personally began paying a lot
more attention to not just the climate
crisis but the the political climate of
the world around me it's around age 14.
um when I've really started gaining an
understanding of all the news headlines
uh that were coming through and from
that point it just seemed that every
single year things got worse and worse
and scarier and scarier so in 2018 I
started finally trying to do something
about that so 2018 is when Extinction
Rebellion really became popular in the
UK and that's when I started getting
involved in marches in petitions in
writing letters to my Member of
Parliament but then I realized that none
of that made a difference no matter how
many marches I went on or how many
positions I signed there was no actual
change happening you know a petition
could be signed by millions of people it
gets sent to Parliament of a House of
Commons they debate it throw it away and
are done by their lunch break you know
those methods didn't work and it was so
frustrating so I joined just enough oil
because we are a peaceful protest group
who use methods of Civil Disobedience
and non-violent direct action to
actually make change happen and it
really feels that since I've started
taking action with just stop oil but
finally what we're doing is making a
difference
yeah I think for me I am I became aware
of it it sounds a funny thing because I
think now we all are quite aware of the
climate crisis or to some extent but I
became aware of it probably around five
years ago and at first I think I only
connected with it intellectually you
know you look at these science and the
facts and these predictions and it's
easy to connect with it intellectually
it's you can understand it but I'd ask
anyone listening to this right now to
connect with it emotionally
because for me that that's when I knew I
had to do something about it because as
a young person I'm terrified about the
future we're facing are you ready are
you really though are you really
terrified are you really uh uh concerned
uh for your life are you you know afraid
of what's really going to happen and if
yes what do you think really will happen
like how what how bad you think it's
gonna get if your concern is truly
climate change that this thing's Gonna
Change how bad you think things are
going to be because AOC said we we may
be you know seizing to exist in 12 years
and I'm sure you guys have seen that
when she said that a couple years ago
and you know Greta you know thundberg is
going around talking about how she
called them uh called out a lot of
different political leaders around the
world for not doing anything and she
went out there and she got noticed by a
lot of different people are you truly
concerned about your future when it
comes down to climate change
yeah I really am last year sir David
King who was the uh former Chief
Scientific Advisor in the UK so what we
do in the next three to four years will
determine the future of humanity because
there's these tipping points that
scientists warn us of which when you
surpass them you've done irreversible
harm it doesn't matter the kind of
policy changes we make or the
sustainable changes we make once you
surpass those tipping points
irreversible harm has been done this was
a young person I'm terrified I'm going
to be denied the right to grow old I'm
terrified I'm going to live in constant
fear of climate disaster I'm terrified
that I won't have access to clean water
or food and we know that these fears are
real because right now millions in the
global South are living the realities of
these fears and they're the people that
have done the least to cause the climate
crisis
so what do you what do you think what do
you think about it and and I'm listen
I'm not in this space neither are you
guys this is something you're protesting
I have my own things I protest that's
important to me you know we all have
lived our lives and I have to we have to
respect everyone's concerns fears and
passions that they have in their lives
but what what do you think about rich uh
people who work for these large
insurance companies do you think they
like losing money
can you guys hear me or no I mean I
don't think anyone likes using money
that's why we have to use disruptive
tactics and you know in the UK right now
we are entering an awful cost of living
crisis right yeah earlier this year the
head of British Petroleum one of the
biggest oil companies in the UK so he
has more money than he knows what to do
with he has the audacity to say that
when our country is plunged into this
cost of living crisis where this winter
families are going to be forced to
choose between Heating and eating
parents are starving themselves so that
they can feed their children
I'm ahead of this massive oil company
says he has more money than he knows
what to do with yeah so but let me let
me give you an idea where I was going
with this question on what uh what
What's the one data that gets this
argument to be done with is a lot of
these actuaries in the insurance
industry their job is to underwrite the
billions of dollars that they're sitting
on to protect it like their job is to
manage risk that's what they get paid to
do they go to universities they come out
and they're supposed to study every
single thing and then this insurance
company is sitting on say 50 billion
dollars 20 billion dollars and you're
coming and saying I want to get XYZ
Insurance 30 years from now 20 years
from now insurance cost of insurance is
going lower life insurance different
kinds of insurance that's going lower
because people are thinking we're going
to live longer life expectancy has gone
higher in many different countries in
the world and the only reason actuaries
are charging life insurance to be so
cheap is because they're thinking we're
going to live 200 like odds are right
now if Phoebe and I'm a little concerned
for you guys you guys are two young
healthy attractive girls you're probably
gonna live to a hundred it's all gonna
be all right for you to be afraid of the
fact that the end of the world is coming
kind of uh prevents you some of your
best years of your life to enjoy
yourself now don't get me wrong I love
the fact that you have a passion but
what do you think about these actuaries
and these billion dollar insurance
companies that when they do the math
they sit there and say you're probably
going to live 200 years old and if
that's the case that means maybe AOC and
Greta are wrong what do you think about
these guys that went to school and they
do math all day just a boring life and
they try to protect the billions of
dollars of these insurance companies
okay so this year we have the worst
droughts in 500 years that destroyed a
third of our wheat crop half of our
potato crop in the UK we uh this summer
we reached 40 degree heat which is
something that was not predicted to
happen by scientists until 2050. in
those just 48 Hours of 40 degree heat
1700 people died of heat exhaustion the
NHS ambulances were put on black alert
fire brigade had the busiest day since
the blitz you know we're not worried
about our future because we don't have a
future to be worried about this climate
crisis is happening right now we got so
lucky that this Summer that heat only
lasted 48 Hours next summer it's going
to last even longer next summer even
more people are going to die but no
let's look sooner than this summer okay
let's look at this winter in just a few
months two-thirds of the UK families are
going to be forced into fuel poverty you
know children are going to freeze to
death in their own homes because our
government are too lazy and too
incompetent and too downright abusive to
care about us we're not fighting for
some distant future we can't afford to
think that far ahead I don't care about
life insurance because I'm not going to
live long enough to cash it in I I
understand what you're saying yeah
I'm optimistic I just want to get to 25
that's my only goal right now you know
it's it's I understand what you're
saying and I I respect your passion and
it's obvious it's very sincere and
you're you're you're truly concerned
about this uh but I will tell you to me
a lot of time when you when you look at
these greedy people the good thing about
greedy people is you know if their life
revolves around money so let's you know
the person you guys were talking about
earlier that he says I have so much
money I can't even count so let's let's
judge those greedy people the benefit
about greedy people is they're they're
it's a very honest relationship what
matters to them is protecting their
money and not risk losing their money
right they're not willing to risk all
the money that they've made and if
insurance companies are still given
insurance policies to people thinking
you're going to live another 80 years
that means that future is bright but you
know the the part of protesting for you
and for you to do what you do super
necessary go make your case people are
going to debate you they're going to
argue with you I remember when Al Gore
30 years ago said we're supposed to be
dead today you know and Al Gore's
documentary when he came up and he said
I don't know what it was 25 years ago or
30 years ago and a lot of people sat
there and said what happened your
argument just didn't have any
credibility but it got a lot of young
people to go out there and March and
protest and get excited about it so it's
a very effective message
say that again
crisis I'm not saying that 10 years now
we're going to die people are dying now
right now because for climate crisis
right right well go ahead Katie So
Yesterday a lady that was involved in a
car crash actually linked to one of my
circle of friends she died because an
ambulance couldn't get through because
your protesters just stopped oil were
blocking the road and the ambulance
couldn't get through in time she
couldn't get the help she needed and she
died earlier you said that you are a
peaceful protesters my friend is dead
how do you answer that
we have a um we have a blue light policy
um which means whenever we have
roadblocks as soon as we um hear sirens
we see the blue lights people move out
of the way even when people are gluing
in the road there's always one lane that
is kept um clear so that people can move
out of the way and we have never had any
complaints from either ambulances fire
brigade or any other Emergency Services
the video footage exists and the lady
can't complain now because she's dead
let me ask you another question Phoebe
let me ask you what bills do you
currently pay who pays for your
accommodation at University
my student loan
when have you ever paid any bills in
your lifetime
no so you don't know what it's like to
be a homeowner and not to be able to
afford your energy bills and then see
some stupid young people throwing soup
over a painting in a gallery that has
nothing to do with the fact they can't
afford to pay their bills you don't know
what it's like to pay a bill Phoebe do
you no but I have empathy for those
people
you know this the climate crisis is
fueled but the cost of living crisis is
fueled by the cost of oil crisis they
are both one crisis it's a crisis of
greed of our government and their
billionaire friends what do you
understand about an ordinary family who
can't afford to pay their fuel bills who
needs ordinary fuel to be delivered but
because of green taxation their bills
are now so expensive they can't afford
them and if we stop oil how much more
expensive do you think fuel is going to
be Phoebe or is it that you're just
spouting out words that you and your
friend think look good how is it related
to stopping oil to throw soup over a
painting in a gallery how is that
related how is it helping the poorest
people in my country
I understand that right now fossil fuels
are subsidized 32 times more than
Renewables even though Renewables are
nine times cheaper would you rather your
bills were 3500 pounds or 400 pounds I
would rather that you and your friends
stopped wreaking havoc in the city of
London I'd rather you stop throwing soup
over paintings stop putting orange paint
on the Windows of Harrods stop sitting
in roads so that my friend couldn't get
the treatment that she needed and I'd
rather you went out worked a bit maybe
you could do some litter picking on a
beach maybe you could do something that
was practical and helpful but I don't
think being obtrusive and obstructive
and lecturing Ordinary People when you
have no idea what it's like to try and
work and make ends meet in the UK you
talk about millions of people you talk
about people who are in poverty you have
no idea what that's like because you
live in the rarified atmosphere of a
University at some wokarati place and
you think what you're doing is changing
the planet I think what you're doing is
pissing people off and I think you could
allocate your energies more effectively
by going out and picking up picking up
litter on a beach
thank you
um I just want to empathize with you
Katie but it truly does break my heart
to hear about your friend
um it really does but I really want you
to understand that myself and Phoebe are
acting out of fear you know we are
terrified that you shouldn't be my
darlings you shouldn't be you have been
fed a load of nonsense you're gonna live
way past 25 and I hope you live till 100
and have a brilliant brilliant life
young people should not be in a place
where you're being intimidated by fear
you should be living the best life you
can jump jump and your wings will unfurl
on the way down you're limiting your
whole world
we should be living outstanding throwing
soup in a gallery
because it's it has to be done with
fighting for our lives here the only way
we can make the change happen is if we
make systematic change I completely
empathize with you and I want you to
understand that this disruption that we
are causing will stop immediately as
soon as the government releases a
meaningful statement that they will stop
producing more fossil fuels it's as easy
as that but you I understand your anger
I really do I really understand your
frustration and I'm angry and frustrated
I really really am and but all this can
stop the minute the government's not
true because we need more fuel we need
more fuel supply one of the things about
supply and demand as you'll know is if
supplies restricted demand Remains the
Same prices go up it's basic economics
we don't have enough fuel supply
stopping oil is not going to help with
pricing you talk about Renewables
they're not there ready to take over
from oil well we currently have eight
years worth of oil in reserve so if we
stop new oil licenses now we would still
have eight years to make a just some
Fair transition to becoming a completely
renewable Society the biggest solar farm
in the UK was built in six weeks you
know we're in Ireland right now we could
be harnessing tidal power a current a
tidal power currently accounts for 10 of
our UK's energy I hear your stats I hear
your stats but do you see that you're
going to need to bring the general
population with you and people's opinion
with you and I don't believe you're
going to bring any people's opinion with
you when you're stood throwing soup and
artwork
well you know this isn't a popularity
contest the suffragettes were famously
hated Martin Luther King was voted the
most hated man in America when he was
alive and the thing is that right now we
know that these tactics of non-violent
civil resistance do work I'm sat here
today as a queer person and the reason
I'm able to vote the reason I'm able to
go to university the reason I'm able to
hopefully will someday will marry the
person I love is because of people who
have taken part in these acts of
non-violent civil resistance before me
well I'm I'm uh not to cut you guys off
I'm actually a food waste activist and
the fact that you guys do soup on the
painting really bother me because I'm
pretty sure there was hungry people
outside that would have loved to have
eaten it so because of that I'm gonna go
fill up my gas tank I have I have to
listen ladies I gotta tell everyone uh
did you want to say yeah just one quick
question for you
um I applaud what you guys are doing we
are facing here's Beyond two tenses
um kudos to you guys for for at least
being very passionate about something 20
years old I you know if you're both 20 I
was not half as passionate about
anything as you guys are so respect on
that but there is a famous quote out
there that says when you're young and if
you're not liberal you have no heart but
if you're as you get older if you're not
a conservative you have no brain so you
guys are going to figure that out along
the way we all are so respect you here
are my two questions legitimately what
pronouns do you identify with that's
number one number two if there's a
hundred of your friends in a room and
you talk about your top
issues that you care about what's number
one two and three meaning climate LGBT
rights the economy health care so
pronouns and your issues if you
uh so I used they she he pronouns
whatever you're in the mood for
um and for me I think the climate crisis
and also the cost of living crisis are
uniquely unifying
because this will affect everyone
and your friend
I also go by Bay van for announce I also
don't see how that comes into this
argument because the this is what we're
facing is climate crisis goes beyond
anything to do with gender sexuality
but I completely agree with Phoebe the
main concern my friends and I talk about
is the climate crisis and the cost of
living crisis my University had to open
a food bank for its students this week
that's how dire things are students who
are already getting a loan by the
government to pay for things like this
can't even afford to buy food using that
loan yeah it's all the energy bills
because of the climate crisis Phoebe our
biggest
condensed meat and just feeding
ourselves Phoebe Anna if you had an
outcome that you wanted to get with what
you did you got it you guys were able to
get the attentions of others to present
your argument and I I applaud you for
your emotional control because you were
pushed uh and folks came at you here and
you were able to give your argument now
whether the audience agrees or not it is
what it is whether anybody system agrees
with you or not it is what it is I plot
you guys to be respectful in return and
I value that so thank you so much for
coming on and sharing your views uh we
appreciate you guys have a wonderful day
guys the future looks very bright by the
way just so you know I believe the
future looks very bright take care guys
take care thank you thank you Phoebe
thank you Anna take care so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
foreign
[Music]